سندخل الى هذه المنطقه مخيم البريج لنرى
حجم الدمار الكبير هناك قناصه للاحتلال في
عدد من المنازل لازالت
متواجده هذا المسجد تم تدميره بشكل كامل
هذه المنطقه التي تعرضت هنا لقصف كبير
مسجد
هنا الفرقان تم تدميره بشكل كامل من
مقاتلات الاحتلال الحربيه
كذلك منازل المواطنين هنا تم
قصفها حرائق في
المنازل دمار كبير خلفته اله الاحتلال بعد
الانسحاب الجزئي من مخيم البريج
وهذه المباني التي
قصفتها المقاتلات
الحربيه مربعات سكنيه كامله قد دمرتها اله
الاحتلال طائرات الاحتلال دبابات احتلال
يعني اشبه بزلزال قوي قد ضرب مخيم
البريج سن تجول يعني الى مناطق ابعد داخل
المخيم لنرصد لكم الدمار الكبير
والهائل الذي خلفته المقاتلات الحربيه
وخلفته اله الاحتلال الدبابات والجرافات
التي دخلت الى مخيم البريج اثناء العمليه
البريه لقوات
الاحتلال يعني هنا انفجارات قويه تسمع
الان في جنوب مخيم البريج المنطقه
الجنوبيه لمقيم البريج يسمع عده انفجارات
الان هذا الدمار
والخراب كما نتابع
واياكم المنازل التي قصفت
ودمرت بشكل
كامل الدمار الكبير
والواسع
نسير
نعم يعني نستمع واياكم الى الانفجارات
القويه في هذه اللحظات يعني سنغادر هذه
المنطقه في هذه اللحظات بعد القصف العنيف
الان قالوا اطلعوا من المدرسه كنساء
توجهوا للبوابه الخلفيه طلعنا تفاجئت
قالوا لي تعالي انت عشقه دخلوني فتشوني
تفتيش ذاتي وربطوا ايدي وغم عيني واخذوني
في شنيه تفقيت لقيت حالي بمكان ما بعرف
انا وين ورحت بعد ما رحت قعدت يوم نيموني
على الرمل في الردم غد وبعد هيك لما عرفوا
انه جنسيتي مصريه رموني عن سريم وقالوا لي
خذيها ماشي بعرفش انه ماخذين زوجي وماخذين
ابني انا زوجي اعمى وابني اعمى ومعي
اثباتات بالشيء هذا ومعي تقاريرهم ومعي
كرن هتهم اتفاجت ماخذين لما روحت هنا شده
الصليب الاحمر كل ما احكي معه يقول لي
بنعرف عنهم معلومات ما زال زوجك بالاعتقال
ما زال زئي بالاعتقال ابني امبارح روحو
رموه في معبر كيرم ابو سالم وهو اعمى كليه
انا امل بنت وولد انا مش حارقني ابني انا
مش محروقه على ابني ابني زي زي اي شان بس
اللي حرقني بنتي بنتي عمرها ما بعدت عني
يوم نفسي افهم بس ايش عامله بنتي او ابني
اللي اخذوه من يهود وين الضمير الحي وين
البني ادمين وين الام العربيه وينهم وينهم
احنا كبني ادمين ايش الذنب اللي اضفناه
ايش اطرفت بنتي عشان ياخذوها مش لاقين حد
يوان وهنا نا ثلاث شهور في المدارس لا اكل
ولا شرب مش عايزه حاجه من الدنيا ارجع
بيتي بس ارجع بيتي بيتي
راح كل اللي في المدرسه غلامه ما بيعملوا
شي ولا بيروحوا ولا بيجوا ونا قاعدين
وقافلين الباب علينا ماحدش حاسس فينا ولا
شي بعدي لنا مش قادرين مش قادرين نتحمل
مريضه كلا انا ومريضه سكر وضغط مش لاقي
علاج الي علاج ما في يجي بدي لي هنا
طائرات كواد كابتر هنا في مخيم البريش
اجزاء من هذه
الطائره هنا هذه الاجزاء من طائره كواد
كابتر في مخيم البريج ربما هي طائرات
انتحاريه تنفذ عمليات اغتيال او عمليات
استهداف
للمواطنين داخل مخيم البريج
هذه
الطائره يعني اجزاء من حطام طائره كواد
كابتر داخل مخيم البري
ه كانت تطخ علينا في المدرسه يعني في
المدرسه شو مها هذه الطائره كانت في
المدرسه هذه كانت تقف على باب المدرسه وطخ
على الناس يعني هذ الطال كان تطلق النار
تخليش ولا زلمه في في الممار بالمره الكل
ينام على الشارع ينام على
الارض